the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video in this video
i want to show you something i found the
other day that i think is interesting as
i was surfing the internet reading up on
different articles and watching older
interviews looking for something
interesting or worthy of discussing in a
video i found something that might
reveal new information about the ending
george rr martin has in mind for a song
of ice and fire now i do want to say
this might not mean that much to some of
you but i still think it is kind of
fascinating because it might at the very
least give us a glimpse of the ending
george r martin wants for his a song of
ice and fire novels this was revealed
when one of the game of thrones actor
sat down for an interview to discuss how
he thought this show would end if you
would like to see the full interview
that link will be down below in the
description now let me show you what was
said during this interview over at ign
everyone's dead for a start everyone's
going to die i think daenerys is going
to have some weird kind of dragon jon
snow baby because everybody knows if you
have sex on television even once you
always get pregnant i don't know maybe
that child prodigy whatever it is will
sit on i don't know or maybe
or maybe it will come out and kill them
all i think it's going to be pretty
brutal but is everybody going to be
killed i don't think everybody can be
killed can they i remember remembering
something george or martin said it was
something just uh
just snow or winds or something like
that and everything blown to
annihilation or something like that i
have no idea and i just want to be
surprised by it really
i remember remembering something george
or martin said it was something just uh
just snow or winds or something like
that and everything blown to
annihilation or something like that i
have no idea and i just want to be
surprised by it really now as you can
see the actor said he remembered george
rr martin saying something about the
ending involving snow or winds blowing
everything to annihilation
now what the hell do you think that
actually means obviously the first thing
that came to mind for me is the white
walkers riding down on the winds of
winter to extinguish everything we know
as life in westeros it sounds a lot like
one of old man's stories when she
described what happened during the first
long night when the white walkers
invaded westeros south of the wall what
do you know about fear
fear is for the winter when the snows
fall a hundred feet deep
fear is for the long night when the sun
hides for years and children are born
and live and die all in darkness
i think most of us do expect something
like this to happen especially since we
know the next book is called the winds
of winter and george r martin has always
said it will feature the white walkers
unlike any others other novels ever have
to date now let's say the actor is right
and he actually does remember george
saying something like this do you think
it might mean the white walkers will
invade further south and some of us may
have initially thought now i certainly
expect the white walkers will make it
much further south than they did in the
show but this sounds like something much
worse considering he said the snow or
the winds will blow everything to
annihilation that sounds like the white
walkers are about to bring one hell of a
storm then again who really knows maybe
he is misremembering what george rr
martin said let me know what you think
down below
does this sound like something you think
we will see in the winds of winter and
let me know what you think this might
mean for our beloved characters in
westeros i'm always interested in
hearing what all of you have to say
as always i want to thank everyone for
stopping by and watching the video i
hope all of you have a great day i will
see you soon
bye
whatever the ending is it'll be
epic and
cataclysmic
i think john
he's had it rough
he's had a rough few years to be fair to
him he died
and he thought that was it
and then he didn't
and he's back and he fought and he's
fought and he's fought and he's lost
friends he's lost family yeah no he if
anyone deserves a happy ending i think
tyrion would be
would
be a good person to
occupy that seat
i don't know how but that that way he
would be because i think given what he's
been through and the skills that he has
he'd probably be the best
the best ruler the best leader tyrion
seems to be the the one who could might
want to
and probably might do a good job so i
can't really see anyone else
that i would vote for i think everyone
else has a tendency to go bonkers and
just
become a dictator
surely not a targaryen
after all that
you never know tyrion is kind of the
obvious choice so i don't think it's
gonna happen even though i would like it
to happen i don't think it's gonna
happen
it would be nice in a way to see
possibly a sisterhood maybe arya
and sansa together i think they're kind
of two sides of the same coin or
something and together might be quite
strong are you start
i thought it would always seem
somehow not only right but in tone with
the world that she would end up but then
we wouldn't know what was going to
happen
everyone's dead for a start everyone's
going to die i think daenerys is gonna
have some weird kind of dragon jon snow
baby because everybody knows if you have
sex on television even once you always
get pregnant i don't know maybe that
child prodigy whatever it is will sit on
i don't know or maybe
or maybe it will come out and kill them
all i think it's going to be pretty
brutal but is everybody going to be
killed i don't think everybody can be
killed can they i remember remembering
something george or martin said it was
something just
just snow or winds or something like
that and everything blown to
annihilation or something like that i
have no idea and i just want to be
surprised by it really but then i just
feel like this green shoot through the
ash and i don't know what that green
shoot is i'm just like a glimmer of hope
it's got to be bittersweet
because you can't
please everyone
especially if you want to be bold
and the one thing we can guarantee is
that there's going to be something bold
happening
i use the word bold as in you know
you're not going to miss that i really
like the idea that we saw the ending
years ago when daenerys goes to that
building and she sees the iron he sees
the iron throne covered in snow and the
room like decimated i really like the
idea that since series two we've known
how it's going to end i love that that
we've just been watching and it's all
been pointless we've seen it all before
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
you